When a user taps inside the Emoji
text field, any existing text clears.
So one could guess that it happens where
textFieldDidBeginEditing is called.
Both the Emoji text field and
the Colorizer text field
are manipulating user generated text,
so we can guess that
their delegates both implement
should change characters in range.
We also know that in the Colorizer,
the keyboard dismisses
upon pressing return, so
we can guess that the colorizer delegate
implements text field should return.
Let's take a look at
the Emoji del again.
If we look inside the text
field did begin editing method
down here at the end of the file, we can
see in this line of code that as soon as
the user clicks into the text field,
the text is cleared.
So what about the rest of the Emoji
delegate's functionality?
Let's scroll up to the top of the file.
Up here we can see a dictionary
that maps animal words
to Emoji symbols to
replace those words with.
By the way, don't worry if you've
never seen a dictionary before.
We're going to discuss Swift
dictionaries in the next lesson.
Most of the action is happening in this
shouldChangeCharactersInRange method.
Whenever the text changes,
the delegate is told,
then it proceeds through these steps.
It constructs a new string.
It looks for each Emoji string, and
then replaces Emoji strings
with Emoji characters.
If we replace a string with
an Emoji we return false here, and
if not, we return true and
let the text field modify the text.
Now, let's see how the Colorizer works.
Remember, the Colorizer closed to
the keyboard on pressing Return,
which is probably the user experience or
after.
So, let's take a look
at how this was done.
You'll want to scroll down to where
the text field should return method is.
And here in the text field
should return method,
you can see this call to text
field resign first responder.
Any time a keyboard starts editing, we
say that it becomes the first responder.
That's why touches to the keyboard
only show up in the current text view
instead of all of them.
Resigning this first responder
status dismisses the keyboard.
So, what else is going
on in this delegate?
If we scroll up to the top, we can see
that just like the Emoji delegate,
this Colorizer delegate
also has a dictionary.
This dictionary maps color
strings to UI color objects.
Whenever the text changes,
this loop finds all of the color
words in the new string.
It creates an array of color objects
corresponding to the color strings, and
then passes that array into a helper
message which blends the colors.
You can see this blend color array
helper method down here, and here you
can see the text color of the text field
is being set to the blended color.